qué podría pasar en el juicio y si la
decisión sería o no vinculante para
rusia
no
russian nuevo no no es vinculante para
rusia el sistema internacional no es
como un sistema nacional donde la ley se
aplica obligatoriamente acá se aplica en
alimentar nacional los países soberanos
y entonces si rusia no acepta ser parte
de ese juicio ese juicio no la toca
rusia es así pero lamentablemente esto
estamos viendo la catástrofe estamos
viendo en rusia en ucrania tras muestra
de una falla por diseño el mundo
internacional no está realizado entonces
cada país hace lo que quiere y bueno rus
invade los demás se quejan pero nadie
puede hacer nada por un sistema mundial
la única opción es la corte penal
internacional no por el crimen de
agresión que nos puede hacer pero si la
guerra es lo único que hay la única
herramienta que tenemos internacionales
es hay nada más si no vas entonces esta
demanda de ucrania tendría alguna
consecuencia o ninguna
ninguna
perfecto y rusia rusia alega un
genocidio por parte de las fuerzas rusas
de las fuerzas ucranianas contra los
habitantes de las regiones separatistas
de donges y lugansk y dice que por eso
comenzó el ataque que tan ciertas son
esas acusaciones y en el campo legal
sería una ración válida no es una excusa
si rusia cree que hay un genocidio en
ucrania tienen la oportunidad de abren
pruebas al fiscal de la corte penal
internacional que tiene jurisdicción en
ucrania y fiscal hay una la única
institución mundial que puede actuar acá
en que tiene poder para actuar que
investiga crímenes en la corte penal
internacional que también está en la
haya pero no son relaciones de estados
son crímenes entonces y rusia cree que
ucrania comete un genocidio
de
evidencia artística que va a actuar que
puede investigar
pero es una cosa absurda
y que podría pasar en la corte penal
internacional
bueno la corte penal internacional está
en el sica ya anunció está investigando
crímenes de guerra
puede ser que haya generales rusos o si
suscribirá evidencia el propio putin que
fueron reforzadas preso
internacional puede hacer es apoyar a
esa única institución que puede hacer
algo darle fuerzas del fiscal y promover
evidencia ya generar evidencia ya para
mostrar fines de guerra y esos
responsables y vendo casos como los
arresta pero ya hoy para los crímenes es
el objetivo